Minnesota trying to snap a losing streak on home
ICE they've dropped their last six here comes
capriso in capriso for a shot and a shoulder
save by sokin that deflex up and out of play
they've got no points to give up and surrender
so they've just been riding their number one
goendale drops it back to leave for a shot and a
save by flurry by Baldi but capriso works off the
board poke checked off of his stick recovered
by zuk gello across to Baldi a shot save soken
rebound goes to the corner pellet can't get it by
Faber at the line baly for ericon and the slot a
shot off the post rebound controlled by Baldi
on the wall he gets this one in the slot very
similar to where Anders Lee was right off the zuk
Carell down low capriso takes a whack behind the
net from Dobson Baldi out to Faber Faber zuk
Carell a shot [Applause] [Music] scores yeah I
was curious how Brock fber would run this power
play you got everybody back he's going to have
the confidence a nice little play there and it's
the movement at the top of the point that draws
the Islanders defense out to the middle of the
ice get their skates going the wrong direction
feeds Matt zuk Carell and he doesn't bother going
north I think sometimes teams can be guilty of
just kind of resting on their Laurels a little
bit when some of their star players come back
but that's where the start to this game has been
encouraging down low barzel his shot deflects to
the wall Horvat over to hold of for New York comes
free to Dobson back to barzel shot Sav by flurry
great sequence there from the wild top unit AO
with a shot saved by flurry and poino Carries to
center right Felino fires and a save made by sokin
he then covers absolutely in the Islanders with a
bunch on there I mean kak poo to he probably has
five of his 600 points in an Islander sweater Mike
Riley's joined this club recently technically not
a Minnesota native but grew up in Minnesota this
one's off the post from Horvat couldn't get one
by flurry yeah the Islanders this their second
chance from the slot Anders Lee the first and
Horvat with some space there off a nice little
feed quick wrer barzel with it across for Nelson
Nelson and Dobson play catch dos in a shot save
rebound the clearing attempt hit G row Islanders
able to maintain the Zone well those failed clears
usually come back to Bern you they have a chance
time to clear it don't get it down toson Nelson a
drive pad save flurry Riley lays across to the
near side for in ball back to R H ball a drive
pad save flurry back to hunt across Johansson
back to hunt now Rossi Rossi fires had a save
by soken Rossi got it back 15 in the power
play Hartman shot sails over the top of the
goal there was a lot to like about
the Wilds first period score aside
just the pace the intensity was different
here's a takeaway and a chance for Dy score
Conor der heading at a point and 17 lights the
lamp for Minnesota it's two wild Calenders and
AO into an indirect passing play that is just
never going to connect endure ready good spot
on his toes jumps that poor pass finds some
room in the middle of the ice AO can't recover
in Time Low blocker doer hits his Mark soken
can't catch up to it give to Johansson back to
Hartman Johansson with a tip save soken rebound
loose Middleton had a chance and soken hangs on
tough breakout turnover nice little Middle
Lane Drive a kick out there and then it's
the defender up in the rush that's Middleton he
makes the breakout pass but he doesn't rest on
his Laurels he gets up there collects this
rebound second chance and those numbers go
back to the day that Guston came out here's
maroon on the backand a save by soken puck is
still loose soken trying to pin it up against
the near side pipe first period where he just
uses that flexibility he's almost full splits
there and it's up underneath his steel pinched
against the post it's loosen there a lot of
sticks but yeah just stuck right under the
steel pal Mar had to help out there all
hands on deck for the Islanders given
goal with zuk Carell back to capriso
again Centered for Eric seni wanted a
tip it goes just wide Baldi in behind
for zukaro to capriso centers Aron X
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music] scores
you don't succeed try and try again and I've
tried for Eric s early in this shift Matt zuk
Carell did in the first it's open he just gets
a little higher in the slot presents that
stick but again it's about Puck retrievals
the Islanders had chances lose pucks the wild
just outnumbered them wanted they're making
the right reads the right plays they're passing
at the right time here's a turnover however and
it leads to a chance for Clutterbuck that goes
off the crossbar flurry says thank you very much
in his role that's a bol load and I think flurry
I think he gets a piece of this right before it
catches the crossbar got it through to capriso he
fires saved by sokin rebound chance and it's just
wide fa has it and at the horn he sends it wide
22 shots on goal and not easy ones either Capri
off in the dying seconds walking down Broadway
and there just cha Johansson fakes the shot
still has it in the corner Rossi spins away from
fashing got it back to hunt hunt a shot off the
post rebound picked up by Rossi Stripped Away
by Romanov this inexperienced golender ah yeah
boy Riley plays it in Pou works out
from behind the net a shot saved by
flurry rebound Holstrom p as he sets
up in gry's office comes out makes a
play and two Islanders on the backside
get something on [Applause] [Music]
that Pino trying to force it out of the Zone
stops in at Center poke checked away it's a
two-on-one short-handed Eric s moves in a shot
he scores second of the night for Eric s and
the short-handed goal makes it 40 Minnesota look
at all three of the wild killers in that little
quadrant they the good sticks kept it in that spot
and then gets out to the neutral zone another good
stick from Marcus Felino dislodges this puck
gets it to Eric s they're Off to the Races two
onone and you give Eric s this [Applause] shot I
think you got to get cred to the coaching staff
too there hasn't been Panic you know they
they challenge the guys the guys responded
themselves been complete one minute remaining
in the third 1 minute and the Wild score again
to make it [Music] five toward the Finish Line
what a pass across from gdo to Felino well just
a pretty passing play Al together it's broin with
the keep with the blue line taking the middle ice
drow with a nice one touch to Felino Patrick La
as we've talked about so many times his hero as
a youngster pelet fires wide final seconds
and there it is a shut out for flry for 552